hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to rust with my good
friend Bob over there
say hi Bob hey hey ah I don't know what
just happened I just forgot how to talk
whatever it's me yes it's funny okay
anyway so we're back with rust and you
may be looking around very confused like
what's going on they seem to have stuff
well yes we do have stuff including guns
we're not in the same place that we were
before and we have learned a lot since
then
well I've learned a lot uh no no I
haven't learned anything Bob hasn't
learned anything don't tell the promise
much for me I was playing on my own on
this server um and I was adventuring
around quite a bit and I was having a
lot of fun and I made quite a bit of
progress I know almost every single
recipe besides the the metal doors and
metal wall stuff and I know a lot about
crafting I know a lot about making what
you need to get by I know a lot about
something or other I'm just pulling
things out of my ass now Bob please talk
for me I'm doing things uh well I I
didn't build any of this just just just
to be clear mark was like hey come over
here and I was like I'm naked and then
all of this existed and he gave me
everything I'm wearing and and this gun
you make it sound like a really strange
porno that we made come over here I'm
naked next in order a sausage pizza oh
that's beautiful
okay so I just made a bit more ammo what
we're gonna do is we're gonna take
revenge and all those bastards who
stabbed us in the back and told us that
our moms were gay I don't know what do
they say uh uh he was honestly kind of
hard to hear yeah that's right but you
know he was apparently trigger-happy
seduced we learned this after the fact
and I was okay givin em a funny but
we're still gonna get funny we're still
gonna enact our revenge oh also this
server has mods where Bob can actually
use my door which is yeah a white bowl
so also you may notice the mic
has a lot of mods I can craft every
single mod Bob over there has a nice gun
and we're gonna go pillage and burn and
kill everyone that we see
yay yay death destruction mayhem hooray
oh no I appreciate in this game what I
haven't said this before but you can
like draw your bow and arrow or aim down
the sights of your gun while you're
sprinting yeah and it doesn't ruin
everything like it does in battlefield
ooh cool you can just continuously
sprint and do things you know like a
normal person in real life oh I mean hey
this is more realistic I guess
considering that everyone's trying to
kill each other except for the zombies
in the be able to survive a lot of
radiation by slamming down all the pills
hey there it's you know it's DOS that's
probably thing right radiation pills
it's yeah they exist sir that's the
thing I think is this like when umm
Lewis from left 4 dead every time he
gets pills he slams the entire bottle
into his mouth yeah perfectly not no
such things overdose with this screw it
yeah tylenol is good in vast quantities
actually isn't there like the vitamin E
if you take excessive amounts of vitamin
E you'll start tripping balls I I have
heard that you can also trip really hard
on like aspirin or something like mom
like it slowly kills you but you can
sort of like it makes you really high if
you take way too much of it or something
yeah that sounds like a bad thing that
because I mean I know there's a thing
with aspirin and babies you should oh
yeah yeah yeah hey do you see what I see
over there yeah a little will Shaq
Jacqueline isn't that about exactly
where our Shaq was the first time I
played this just about I mean pretty
close basically the entire time we've
been playing this game has been in this
little Valley here
I think our old house used to be just
tucked up there - oh yeah it totally was
is there anything else to this game yes
there's so much more why haven't we seen
the rest of the map I don't know
cuz I mean this is the place where
people kind of stay away from there's a
lot of density down below okay we're
gonna stalk around the left side this I
find it really disconcerting on this I
don't know if it's the server but the
grass folds over into
national Chuck chunks as you run through
it oh yeah yeah I did notice that when I
was crawling that's truly tricky yeah oh
by the way everyone I'm playing on a
different server than I was before
um I've been playing you for a little
bit now quick everyone get on that
server and ruin steam again ah okay so
you want to like cover me and I'll go
break down the door no no what what
what'll happen is I don't know if he's
in there right now
hmm I know the fires on which is very
strange so hang on just keep watch I'll
run screaming if you see anything yeah
but you'll run screaming if I see any
yeah oh yeah we're you know we're
telepathically linked didn't you know
okay okay I see so I see those bears in
the distance still it's all I got don't
look at the beers look at what I'm doing
right here okay huh wait a minute oh no
it's Jaron right at your butt oh it's
empty
oh it's empty someone just thought this
fire on did so oh I think someone's
trying to commandeer this place so oh my
gosh should we hang out and wait for
them to come back okay so my rule you
know every time I've ever played this
game I've not been desert the people
that we are right now I've always been
this dude in this one set I totally get
now why people do that yeah but I
understand how you get to that point in
this game yeah I would never have gotten
here if I were on my own I know you're
welcome you're welcome
haha it's basically the entire game is
hiding as long as you can like a scared
little bunny and then popping out guns
blazing
you know guess when this if this dude
comes back and we kill him he's just
gonna come back and be like oh no
there's guys oh but I don't have
anything they know I don't have anything
maybe I can hide by oh oh [ __ ]
yep yep the player experience for
everyone who ever plays these stuff is
game I'm gonna leave that on so he
doesn't know anything's up yeah you know
okay where are you by the way are you
still by that rock up here crouched
underneath this rock can you not see me
I can't see you at all oh there I barely
could see like wow yeah that was cuz
your cloth armor really kind of bland
okay let's move forward a bit because
why what okay no nevermind thought I saw
something it was a lot I thought I saw
something that was a lie huh
you want to kill these bears uh sure
hi it's pretty easy with spoil yattaman
what Oh know if you shoot then people
will be able to hear who there's another
settlement over there avoid the Bears
there's another cattleman I know there's
a lot of people that do live around here
well cuz there's a spawn right in the
middle this too isn't there I mean it's
not the big thing yeah very true
you spawn and you're gonna need a house
let's go right here right in the middle
of the open oh look at all these
resources I'm sure no one a lot of me
anyone in there no doors not there so I
think it was busted down a long time ago
hmm
there's a deer over here yeah there is
ignore him I wish you had a silencer
maybe once we come back with some stuff
we'll be able to get you one yeah how
much how much does it take to make that
do you see that Shack over there yeah
yeah let's go over there it takes eight
low quality metal which each low quality
metal takes 15 metal Fraga yes you might
have enough metal fragments in that
furnace when we get back day then you're
right we might I put a bunch in it was
at like almost 100 already when we left
huh I'm gonna go ahead and gather Oh guy
in left guy in left John what should we
start shooting no no man what's he doing
I'm stalking to your right I'm staying
behind he's friendly let me let me
convince him Lee hello we're friendly
we're friendly if you're friendly yeah
friendly okay good just trying to get my
okay where are you Bob Bob we're gonna
I'm off to your right I'm flanking you
on the right are we gonna kill him or
what I'm just gonna go up inside Hey
I'll watch ya you seen you got buying
two mcil okay hey you new or are you
just starting out is he looking at me at
all
Oh would Thanks here I'll give you
something in return uh um oh my god is
like I'm giving you stuff I don't really
need it oh well think I'll thank you so
much that's really appreciative um
that's about it I don't really have
anything in return do you want anything
I got some rad pills maybe no I'm fine
how about no no no no no oh no it wasn't
loaded okay leave it alone god damn it
why I walked up behind him and I pulled
the trigger
empty e ah loaded oh that wasn't so much
funnier in my head I don't think it
would have been a yes he was so nice he
gave us 250 wood and 10 chicken oh my
gosh that was his house over there that
was the guy oh man hahahaha oh my god
those amazing oh well there you go
that's what everyone should just do in
this game what gosh sorry I harvested a
bill
okay well now my guns loaded so next
time we can do that again yeah next time
we'll get them actually you should have
the shotgun for this hey this has a
metal door on it always there's someone
in there I don't know I think I see the
outline of something white might be a
furnace I don't see do you oh my gosh
dude look to the left from the from
where we were coming from look to the
left down the hill Oh down there the
fort see that compound yeah is that
that's someone built that right yeah
yeah I think so
it might be ransacked and let's pillage
this place first um should we do the
door or a wall no the wall is
unbreakable its metal but the whole
building can be broken pretty easily
only takes like a hundred strikes so
just start hitting and all all people
just keep a lookout every once in a
while okay if the door opens run cuz
Paisley I missed someone in there okay
I'm looking at what can I don't see
anything I don't see anything do
anything my heart pounding but in a
different way never get that thing when
you play like competitive online and you
just like oh god oh god
someone's gonna oh god someone gonna
kill me but this time I got a different
feel hello what huh ah my stupid head
phone turned off from my headphones okay
I was monologuing there Chris oh you
didn't hear that no hi I heard my
hardest pounding my heart is pounding
faster then I have a heart attack
died he died that's why I was founding
SS dying how many hits does this take I
think a hundred it takes a lot but with
two of us are you that you walking yeah
I was just taking a look I can't I can't
see over where that dude's house was so
I was just stepping back from the tree
yeah you'd be able to get it any minute
now
can I break take all the goodies there's
nothing in here it's gonna be completely
everything you know it would be really
epic if we were doing this and there was
a dude in there with like a shotgun Oh
God he was just waiting and as soon as
it breaks he just like blows our faces
off he wouldn't be able to get both of
us but yeah that would be oh well but
neither of us has a gun out so if he's
really quick he just like blow this both
away one shot each yeah don't say things
like that
I've actually been that guy I was
someone was hammering away at my door
and I heard it and I was like what the
hell is happening and as soon as it
broke I had a shotgun on my blue house
before I moved my compound to secluded
location you know you never mind huh
what like people are gonna try and
figure out where you are now I guess
they don't know what's surfing you're on
no no long as you don't say and so long
as I don't show normal everywhere it's
called markiplier rusts no no no we
thought what's gonna happen haha why
isn't this breaking it thought with the
duo zero break laughter there might be
someone in there fixing it as we're
breaking it are you sure there's not a
person in here I'm pretty sure there's
no one in there actually is a way to fix
things I learned this recently I know I
I I was playing once and this dude like
the first thing I did was go and find
the most secluded spot I could uh-huh
and this dude must have followed me or
something yeah and he was like all I had
was a wood Shack in a wood door and he
was busting trying to bust down my door
but I had like 300 wood and so for like
45 minutes it was just him with a
hatchet trying to break down the door
and me standing there repairing the door
every five seconds
there we go yes oh it's just that's a
hunting bow oh I'll get another starter
kit dude oh I don't care how worthless
it is I'm taking it
we're the worst we're the worst Peavey
piers ever on this thing we didn't get
anything well we're about to go see
what's up over here with this compound
alright um I live today I'm stay to your
left okay yeah just in case someone
spots one of us maybe they won't spot
the other in time I don't know okay got
you actually you should probably take
the shotgun cuz that's perfect for
coming up behind someone just blowing
him away I cannot imagine that an
opportunity like that is gonna present
itself again that was too frigging funny
you missed enough thank you
I didn't know I had that's okay
I forgive you alright this compound
looks like it might be totally jacked up
maybe got a gate Oh what is this what is
this like a little wood shelter out
behind it here yeah yeah go ahead and
harvest any rock you see yeah huh
way ahead of you brother huh yeah you
were to exit route yeah I'm the greatest
I just let you play with me
it doesn't look open it is next intact
no joke it looks totally intact uh
should we try and break in I don't know
how long would I mean is there like a
weak spot is there a door or something
we can go we'd have to go for the walls
but these are structure walls so they
take longer but I don't know how much so
that's let's pick one and and do it
start wailing I don't like there's
anyone in there uh yeah well they can
hear us walking around now so probably
they'd probably hear us banging on it
whoa okay that's the furnace thought I
saw good no okay let's pick this walk is
kind of shadowed all right let's start
wailing
listen bird or the door opens bolt for
it go get ya we're gonna get them okay
we are loving and we're those guys we're
gonna get you yeah I really hope there's
a lot of supplies in here it's hip this
is empty
someone built this as a decoy structure
god damn it I think I saw this place
like when I first came on the server so
it's pretty old I'm surprised it's not
broken into that probably means though
that someone's been living here it's
probably like the admins house or
something
it's griefing allowed on this server are
they gonna like no we can break in it's
totally allowed on the server you can
break in do whatever you want
go all around the place and steal
people's homes like feel free Adam
instead so admin endorses it the admin
probably does it himself did you know
that there's an I looked on the wiki
there's a weapon and armor set for admin
the weapon can instantly break anything
and the end the armor makes him
invisible oh we need some of that
if we can manage to kill an admin no be
a delight the admin with the insta kill
weapon who's invisible yeah let's just
okay over there hey it's done you can't
say something's impossible until Adel so
I feel pretty comfortable saying that
that's impossible
all right cuz it is zero I might fast
through it forward through this part B
just cut cuts like a funny song in or
something do the Benny Hill song we
could just run around a bunch sometimes
for no reason and well oh those you okay
those footsteps really scare me man
Thank You booth but I think the blocking
yeah cuz I can hear it in a sleep uh-huh
someone I think the Benny Hill theme is
actually copyrighted I'm gonna do uh
could do that Jenny Hill theme the Jenny
Hill
did you ever get food by the way huh did
you remember to get food by the way I
have some food yeah okay good I just
want to make sure you didn't starve from
all this exertion now I've got five
cooked chickens okay good that's that's
a lot of food right it's enough food
I've got plenty of beans though bean
beans what the hell are beans beans
beans are these things that are grown in
the ground I don't know if they're like
up are they a magical fruit no they're
not a magical fruit the more you eat no
okay check in the pros
I wish there was some kind of indication
of how well this was going like it's got
like slowly less good looking or or
there was a meter of some sort or my
door got darker as it was going down
that was something I guess we don't have
any sort of light source yes you do on
your gun you have a flashlight no so
excellent okay yeah yeah truck okay good
did you just say don't try it yeah we
get someone might see it come on I don't
know the baby right the house come on
jeez how long is this gonna take good
nervous Bob somebody tell my binders any
minute Minna no this is this is pretty
stressful I know it sucks for the person
whose house we're breaking into but what
if we broke in and replaced the wall and
just waited inside for someone to come
back oh that would be so douchey but
then they spawning all they would find
out to me why don't they live in Finland
and they're not getting on for nine
hours well then it's totally okay this
is gonna take I don't know it's
definitely possible but it's you know oh
I'm looking
oh maybe the pickaxe would have been
better like we were debating that
off-screen like is the pickaxe better
for breaking your room
happy better for breaking I'm starting
to think the drapes are funny but you're
the master so hey thank you Oh God did
you anybody know so metal doors are
unbreakable no they're not unbreakable
they just take like two explosive
charges they're totally unpractical to
break down whereas wood it just you can
do with a kit you can't do a metal door
that like no matter how hard you hit
what if I hit it like really hard
well then it would go yeah you hittin it
hard yet anyway Oh awesome yeah
especially if you talk dirty do it tell
it is pretty and then slide your meat on
does that work on wooden walls
yes because unlike Doctor Who's sonic
screwdriver okay bird-watching I started
and finished watching did you start with
like the 1940s Doctor Who or whenever I
tried look at Emily
I can't boot it was it the next day tip
the head for a little bit I have seen
several episodes of that show I've seen
like oh man I honestly don't I've seen
the one where they're like dealing with
the devil and it's it's not the devil
orders the devil er I don't know hi that
show that's too many episodes for me to
just start watching yeah I need to have
like six weeks of my life where I just
have no responsibilities
yeah and I can watch it uh-huh what I
mean it's not bad if you start it in the
2005 version I think it is is that word
David Tennant is the doctor
that's when what's Chris ecklestein or
Echols oh shut the one or the first uh
like the second episode is with the last
human and the earth is ending oh yeah
that's the one guy yeah that's a guy
he's a guy that rebooted and then I went
to David Tennant and then oh one I
freaking love David Tennant I I want to
watch his his doctor yeah yeah awesome
ah
I really like it a lot a lot of people
think that David Tennant is their
favorite dog and I kind of agree with it
but at the same time a lot of people
don't like Matt Smith but I really like
I really like him
he was the super lanky guy right yeah
yeah the chin guy yeah it's fine I've
never seen that show I know a lot about
Doctor Who because there's an episode of
Top Gear where they have the super lanky
guy I've met Matt Smith or rivers
neighbors and they talk about the
doctors and the actors and I think they
have an episode where David Tennant is
on top here also what's up that show has
given me all of my Doctor Who knowledge
yeah Top Gear actually is a show that I
think I need to still watch it because I
love every time I see like a gif of it
or like a little video of it it just
makes me laugh like everything about it
makes me laugh so it's good they're
really worth it it's funny because when
they do reviews of cars yeah it's like
cool but it's like this is the 2003 Ford
Mondeo like what in the hell is that
even the Ford Mondeo is a model that was
only sold in like England and Europe and
it's actually was the Ford 500 here and
it's the 2003 model yeah that's what
this is guys this on here I guess this
is what they did but yeah but all this
stuff where they ride their motorcycles
through Vietnam that that episodes very
cool and they do a 24-hour race with a
diesel BMW yeah that's like really epic
cool I use that on Netflix I got a quick
though uh I think almost all of it is on
Netflix through season like 16 or 17
it's been around that long I'm gonna
ride along with these guys like the yeah
the same guys on all the seasons really
I did not know that boy they must hey
what's funny is this is only new Top
Gear they actually had like an older I
don't think I've ever seen any of it but
they had an older series that used to be
top here that was not quite the same and
didn't really work out okay am I die of
hunger I didn't think this was gonna
take this long hang on I got I got food
free dropping chicken breast on the
ground there it is oh it's just not as
glorious of a lifestyle as I had thought
it would be no no pillaging is not as
funny
murdering apparently man enough
gunpowder I could create grenades which
would probably blow this would probably
blow the [ __ ] but it might also alert
everyone to the explosion hey I don't
know it's out all he grenade yeah I
can't make it
there's satchel charges that you can
make which are the breaching explosives
that are meant for this
I like silent or quieter there ha and
louder this is taking forever
you wanna abandon our effort I'm gonna
laugh when so are so close are you sure
we are feel like we are it's gotta
happen at some point yeah whatever what
if we're doing something wrong this can
only be opened by like a pickaxe or
something it's made of wood and you keep
hammering I'm gonna look up on the wiki
I'm gonna look up Zepa Zoe's been going
on too long I've got 14 billion cookies
on cookie clicker than I need to spend
Oh I closed the wiki what in the heck is
cookie clicker my little brother was
playing that the other day and I did not
understand the point it's it's a time
waster basically play candy crush like
everyone else oh I don't think these are
breakable it says a wooden wall takes
one explosive charge to destroy if
placed in the center of the wall oh
nothing about hatchets thank you
everybody so much for watching this how
long how long were people screaming in
the comments that we can't break that
wall uh we are the worst bandits ever in
the history of ever
well anyway haha thank you everybody for
watching yeah hope you had a great time
we sure did will thanks Bob for being
here
hey I could help we'll see you in the
next video bye bye
yeah
hi oh my god we're such [ __ ] oh my
god